make way for Chris Simms NBC sports
co-host a pro football talk live with
Mike Florio and I hate lists and they
usually come out at this time of the
year and I saw that Chris Simms had a
list on quarterbacks and I what caught
my eye and that's what you want to do
when you're putting out a list or
something controversial and that was Tom
Brady was ninth on the list of I guess
the quarterback you would want going
into the upcoming season let me bring in
Chris Simms just so before I start to
yell out him that I can get the
rationale for his list Chris thank you
for joining us explain what your
rationale was for this list okay all
right well first off the one thing I
want to make sure we're that we get out
there you know and you talked about it
is it's the slow time of the year right
and let's come out it's part of my job
and I evaluate quarterbacks in your arms
obsessed but I certainly didn't put him
at number nine just to get people I
didn't wait 31 picks to ruffle the fan
base to get attention to my pick I mean
I did that I would have thrown a few
more curveballs in the 20s and 30s too
so this is truly what I believe you know
I have a passion there yes I am doing
this as viewing as the quarterbacks as
they stack up right now heading into the
2019 football season who is the best
quarterback in football and one of the
things that you know again I'm trying to
you know I don't want to say educate but
point out to people here it's the
ultimate team sport we have seen and
come to this thing here in the last 15
to 20 years where it's just quarterback
quarterback quarterback and that's the
only guy that wins and loses the game
and we know that's not true but yet we
boiled it down to that a lot when we
just go into the quarterback
conversation and yes as it stands right
now Tom Brady's still awesome he
certainly you know 2/3 would top three
greatest quarterback of all time the
most decorated of all time not even
close I get that but yes going into the
2019 season Dan I look at him as the
ninth best quarterback in football you
have Eli is the 34th best quarterback
that means quarterbacks who aren't even
starting who are better than him no
doubt about it yes
I mean Jacoby Brissette or Eli Manning
I'm gonna take Jacoby per se you know I
mean Eli Manning's players
below-average I don't think this should
be you know a shock to anybody when you
stack up you know all the quarterbacks
and you sit there and look at it and you
go gosh okay there's some quality
backups on a few of these football teams
to that I think could you know take
advantage of what was there to be had at
the quarterback position better than Eli
Manning at this point of his career
Eli's a legend I know all that but he's
certainly getting up there he's long in
the tooth Dan I evaluate quarterback
play a lot like this I'm not gonna go
down to the oh let's see the win-loss
record and let me see who has the best
stat and then that's just the best
quarterback every year no it's not about
that you know not everybody has the same
support system the same great scheme
around them the great players around
them whatever it may be I am big into
evaluating as far as quarterback play
what was there to be had right on the
field yards wise plays wise and did you
take full advantage of what was there to
be had and then another huge area I look
at is just going ok and then when
there's nothing there right what do you
make happen when there is nothing there
and that is another big factor and I
know a lot of people have a hard time
they go all you had Aaron Rodgers number
one how could you do that there are six
nine and one well it happens in football
all the time but somehow we can't wrap
our heads around it in the in the NFL
level
hey John Elway didn't have the best
season that of any college quarterback
in 1982 when he was at Stanford when
they went what four and seven or five
and seven but the NFL evaluated all the
quarterbacks in college football said
you know what that guy's the best
quarterback Patrick mahomes a few years
ago at Texas Tech he didn't have the
best season and he was five and seven
but the Texas Tech with the Texas Tech
you know Red Raiders but then the NFL
evaluated and most teams came away and
went damn that guy on that five and
seven teams the best quarterback in
college football and again it just
that's why I just try to separate it
there we're talking about the one player
it's not disrespect to Tom Brady he's
truly the guy I tried to model my game
after when I was playing I love him but
you know me then I mean I'm just gonna
keep it real to what I think and my
evaluations and I don't give a damn what
most people
think about that well would you take
Daniel Jones then is your starter over
Eli Manning if you don't even have Eli
in the top you know 32 teams here well I
didn't have Daniel Jones on my top 40 so
I know I had him just outside of my top
40 there I got a seed Daniel Jones first
so I mean I'm hearing very positive
glowing reports about him and I expect
yes I mean this is one thing I've said
with the eli manning daniel Jones
conversation you know he's going to put
pressure on Eli and the Giants because
every day he's gonna be out in the field
and they're gonna go okay he's just as
big as he like whoa he's definitely a
better athlete than Eli
oh gosh his arms better than Eli oh he's
pretty smart and you know that's where I
think you know that's when you start to
go over the coaches see it every day the
players see it every day and that puts
pressure on the situation overall I
still think Eli will be the starter but
if Daniel Jones has a great training
camp and does really well and the Giants
start off one in three or two and four
or something like that
I would not be shocked if Daniel Jones
does supplant Eli Manning as a starting
quarterback there he's Chris Simms NBC
Sports and Pro Football Talk live Monday
through Friday with Mike Florio on NBC
Sports Network Jared Goff is 19th yep
feels like where do you have Sean
McVeigh ranked here on the quarterback
list yeah well you know yes Jared Goff
does a lot of good things but I just
don't look at Jared Goff as being the
quality of player as the guys I do look
in front of them and yeah you know I
mean again Jared Goff done a lot of good
things again and but we've all just go
oh the Rams there in the Superbowl Jared
Goff got to be one of the best
quarterbacks in football right well you
guys watch the Superbowl there was
people open there was throws to be had
and it didn't deliver in fact it was
less than deliver it was ugly in a lot
of the situations so there was moments
last year where I saw Jared Goff do some
of the things that I talked about as far
as good quarterback play and evaluating
at the gate I said who okay there was a
few moments last year where I said
nothing was there and Jared Goff made
something or hey the defense really did
a good job and he threw the perfect
throw against the perfect coverage and
did that but yeah I do need to see more
from Jared Goff it's a great support
system there with the Los Angeles Rams
of course McVeigh is phenomenal the
talent
around him is phenomenal and I certainly
think there's a whole bunch of
quarterbacks that are yes in front of
him if they put them out with the Los
Angeles Rams they whatever every bid
have the same success if not even more
just to let people know the list here
here's your time okay with me oh I'm
Sports mad at you okay okay good I
that's a good way to put it
thank you that's good way to put that
because too many people get personal and
I want to go man there's other things I
like you I just I can be sports mad your
dad I don't like but you I like
Aaron Rodgers then Patrick mahomes
Russell Wilson Andrew Luck deshaun
Watson is a little bit of a surprise at
five Ben at six Matt Ryan seven Cam
Newton eight Tom Brady amend Drew Brees
yeah actually that's your top ten yes
well think about this Sean you know Dan
the one thing I'll say there is
I mean we talk about other quarterbacks
you know they don't have great offensive
line play I mean it's the worst
offensive line play in football last
year was the Houston Texans and then you
know not like they had a great run game
and then what makes the run game good
added on to that that doesn't go in the
stat sheet is the fact that deshaun
Watson and the run game they can design
around him puts more pressure on run
defense which makes Lamar Miller look
better and most people I talked to Dan
and I've gone on the radio and done this
to a few people over the last week ago
who's the other receiver on the Texans
behind DeAndre Hopkins and people go uh
who's the tight end uh so there he is
having years where we go man this guy is
pretty special and the support system is
not great is he perfect yet no but he's
a special special talent and I do I look
at him as one of the five best
quarterbacks in the game is there a
chance Aaron Rodgers ends his career is
overrated yeah certainly there's a
chance that way yeah if he ends with one
Super Bowl yeah yeah I mean that's
that'll be I don't want to say it's
gonna be overrated it's gonna be
disappointing but everybody has said he
could be the greatest quarterback of all
time yes right I don't think he's the
greatest quarterback of all time I mean
hey the quickest to get the 40,000 yards
it's the greatest interception to
touchdown
janna interception ratio in the history
of the sport that's not even close with
whose second and we view him as a
gunslinger and you know again you know
weapons there hasn't been weapons galore
up there no he's got a better weapon he
had better weapons than Brady had a lot
of times well I mean the greatest tight
end of all times played with Aaron
Rodgers has the greatest receiver
arguably of all time played with Aaron
Rodgers the greatest slot receiver we
didn't he didn't play he made Julian
Edelman okay looks like kid anybod was
there and Wes Welker was do really good
there and he was cast off for a
dolphin's you got cast off by the
Dolphins there so they got Wes Welker
top because there's no teams in football
nope in this again I don't want to sound
like I'm hating on Tom Brady because Tom
Brady is freaking awesome I'm just
trying to explain people there's more to
the game than just going wins losses
stats the quarterbacks the reason that's
it if that were the reason the Nick
Foles would never would never beat it
yeah Tom Brady in a super Wow it still
sends beat John Elway but big Wes Welker
okay yeah he went down to Miami and they
typecasted Ivo a white guy we can't
start him at receiver and we don't even
know how to use a receiver like this
because it was time in the era where
again New England is ahead of the curve
where they go hey we can get these like
small little slot receivers and do all
these cool things with them in the
middle of the field and we're one of the
few offenses in football that know how
to utilize it so that's why they got Wes
Welker I mean Edelman Hadean branch was
the number one receiver on another Super
Bowl team after he left New England so
again that's not a knock on Tom Brady
all the great quarterbacks have had good
talent around them for the most part I
just hate when people say that about New
England all the time I find that
disrespectful the rest of the players up
there okay you got one game to win yes
with their respective teams okay with
their teams okay well that's a different
scenario okay but that's why I'm looking
at gray team if you're going to get me
in the New England and then just say you
can have any quarterback I'm gonna still
go with Aaron Rodgers if you're gonna go
give me the team and then give me any
quarterback with it I'm gonna go okay
I'll take the New England team with
Aaron Rodgers
no no Brady's team and Aaron Rodgers
team right
okay okay no England's better
mean hey I mean Aaron Rodgers look at
the place he has to make late in the
fourth quarter the plays the degree of
difficulty are off the charts and then
Brady again not to say that it's easy
but you know Oh Julian Edelman wide open
over the middle on third and ten against
the Kansas City Chiefs and he hit the
receiver that was open over the middle
for attend yard completion I'm not gonna
go Chris oh my gosh how did he do that
that is a slant to Gronk oh my gosh Tom
Brady hit a slant to grok I got a up of
my rankings he can hit slam routes you
know and that's not a knock on Tom Brady
again I know it sounds like that but I'm
trying to explain that the coaching goes
along with it Dan okay wait a minute who
do you love more yeah here a lot more
Aaron Rodgers or your wife hey you're so
funny shut up
you know what as a person Dan I actually
like Tom Brady more I think he's cooler
he can tell your wife I like Brady
better than your wife is a person no I
like my wife top notch I mean my wife is
a hell of a cook she's got a really nice
figure you know nice upper body nice
lower body so no I'm not putting any of
them in front of it I like my wife's
booty a lot so I can't go there does she
move well in the pocket jeido she has no
movement in the fact she's Italian
stallion and she could care less about
football she thinks I'm crazy but she's
just here listen to me talking about
this stuff
is she there now no she just went out
with my little girl here a few minutes
ago great to talk to you I know you're
on vacation by the way who was the worst
quarterback in the NFL oh gosh the worst
quarterback in the NFL I don't know I
mean you know I never went past 40 I
didn't even look at it that way this
year so I didn't get nervous was 75 on
your list
yeah well he's moved up a few spots I'll
give him that
I did I did look at bortles and go hmm
you know I looked at he was definitely
in the 40s for me this year but I didn't
really put much thought past you know 50
really to where I was like Oh looking at
some of those really down the line
in stringers third string quarterback
like I did you know a few years ago when
this list kinda can became a popular
thing Thank You Chris have a great
weekend we appreciate your time
oh you the man dad see you guys that's
Chris Simms NBC sports co-hosted pro
football talk live with Mike Florio oh I
don't know what we accomplished there
but it's always good to get Sims on and
he somehow talks his way into trouble I
don't know if he talks his way out of
jumping for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]